- [Narrator] What's the
weather usually like
in the winter where you live?
If you asked someone in Fairbanks, Alaska
they might describe below freezing days
and navigating through
huge drifts of snow.
If you asked someone
else in Miami, Florida
they might tell you that most days
it was warm enough to go to the beach.
How can two places on the same
continent be so different?
Well, it all comes down
to regional climates.
Climate is the long term pattern
of weather in a particular region.
You can think of it as
the average weather.
A region's climate
depends on many factors,
including its latitude, elevation,
and surrounding geographic features,
such as oceans or mountains.
Let's look at how regional climates depend
on latitude first.
Latitude refers to imaginary lines
that measure how far north or south
a place is from the Equator,
which equally divides the earth in half.
The Equator is marked
at zero degrees latitude
and the mid-latitudes
increase north or south until
they reach the poles,
which are marked at 90 degrees
north and 90 degrees south.
The sun heats the planet unevenly.
So places at higher latitudes,
which are farther from the Equator,
get less direct sunlight
and solar energy on average,
resulting in lower average
annual temperatures.
Places at lower latitudes,
being closer to the Equator,
get more direct sunlight
and solar energy on average,
which results in higher
average annual temperatures.
This uneven heating creates a pattern
of low and high air pressure bands
from the Equator to the poles,
affecting the amount of precipitation
that the different latitudes receive.
In bands where moist air is rising,
mainly at zero degrees latitude
and 60 degrees north and south,
places experience a lot of rainfall,
especially around the Equator.
And bands where dry air is sinking,
like at the poles and 30
degrees north and south,
places experience very little rainfall.
This creates dry conditions
at the cold poles
and desert conditions in regions
near the 30 degree latitude lines.
Another important influence
on regional climates is elevation
or how high a place is above sea level.
As air rises from lower
to higher elevations,
it expands and cools.
That's why regions at higher
elevations, like mountains,
tend to have lower
average air temperatures
than regions at lower elevations.
Speaking of mountains and seas,
the presence of geographic features
can also influence a region's climate.
Let's start by diving into
the impact of water first.
Water heats and cools slowly
while land heats and cools quickly.
As a result, temperature
variations tend to be much smaller
for cities near large bodies of water
than for cities surrounded by land.
For example, let's compare
the yearly temperature ranges
for Vancouver, which is close
to Canada's Pacific Coast
and Winnipeg, which is further East
in the interior of the country.
This line graph follows the
average temperature in Celsius
for each city throughout
the months of the year.
Vancouver starts at
the year mildly chilly.
Temperatures rise a bit
for a warmer summer.
And then slope gradually back down.
Overall, the city sees
a pretty small range
of temperatures throughout the year
because the nearby ocean
influences the local climate
as it gradually warms and cools.
Compared to Vancouver, Winnipeg
has a much colder winter
and a slightly hotter summer resulting
in a more dramatic range of temperatures
throughout the year.
We call a climate like
Vancouver's a Marine Climate
and a climate like Winnipeg's
a Continental Climate.
Things get pretty interesting
when we combine the impact
of water with land forms.
One unique example is a rain shadow,
which can be found in
places where mountains
are relatively close to the ocean.
For example, here's a satellite image
of the Andes Mountain
Range in south America.
The mountains run north
to south in this image
and they're close to the Pacific Ocean.
Notice how the area between the Pacific
and the Andes is green and lush,
but the area behind the
Andes is brown and dry.
That's the rain shadow.
What causes such a huge change?
Well, when warm moisture rich air
from the ocean meets the
mountain it's forced upward.
As it rises the air expands
and cools causing the moisture
to condense and fall as precipitation.
Now, the air is much drier,
which allows it to change
temperature much faster.
As that dry air descends
down the other side
of the mountain it compresses
and quickly becomes warmer,
which leads to increased evaporation.
Overall, this results in
a cool and wet climate
on the ocean side of the mountain
and a warm and dry climate
inside the rain shadow,
which is what we saw
on the satellite view.
As you can see, regional climates
can get pretty complicated
when you consider all of the factors
that can go into them.
Depending on the exact region,
one factor may be more responsible
for the local climate than the others.
Like how the presence of the
Andes Mountains contributes
to the rain shadow climate beyond them.
Let's look back at our
two very different cities
from before so we can see
how the factors we discussed
affect their winter climates.
Fairbanks is at a very
high northern latitude
which helps explain why it's
so freezing in the winter.
Miami is much closer to the
Equator and near an ocean,
so it experiences a very
warm and mild winter.
Which of these cities would you
like to visit in the winter?
Whether you prefer hanging
out on sunny shorelines
or exploring frosty winter wonderlands,
there's a regional climate somewhere
in the world that you'd probably enjoy.